le 5 mai dernier c'est un grand boum et
l'affaissement d'un poteau métallique
qui avait poussé la ville à faire
évacuer le marché en urgence les travaux
de remise aux normes engagé début 2017
se sont donc poursuivies dans un lieu
vide de tout occupant
en effet les 70 poteau attaqué par la
rouille au contact du sol ont tous été
étayées sectionné consolidé par une
semelle béton nous avons dû confronter
bon nombre d'éléments donc les premiers
se font des poteaux estampillée de
photos on a dû reprendre les fondations
de façon précisément à akoupé la base
puisqu'elle était fortement endommagé
et puis par la suite conforter la tête
des poteaux de façon à éviter justement
qu'elle ne puisse trop bouger et vous
avez vu c'est une championne qui
relativement importante donc il peut
subir des efforts buvant des efforts du
éventuellement au séisme l'ensemble du
marché couvert a été remise aux normes
électriques et quelques travaux de
plomberie carrelage peinture et reprise
des balustrades sont toujours en cours
la réouverture annoncée pour ce lundi
est finalement reporté ce sont les
finitions qui sont toujours les plus
difficiles a terminé je pense qu'il
faudrait attendre au moins deux semaines
enfin monsieur le maire va décider c'est
surtout
tous les restaurateurs qu'on voulait
aller plus vite
les marchands même si c'est difficile
quand il pleut mais bon leur situation
leur permet de patienter pas les
restaurateurs donc heureusement ben on
va patienter encore quelques jours
à la différence des marches en plus
mobiles les restaurateurs de la halle
eux n'ont pas plu du tout travaillé
pendant neuf mois pour eux c'est
l'urgence